Larry Arnn:
Senior Class President is Nicholas Brown.
He comes from Columbus, he majored in economics.
He did very well. He didn't do as well as
say, Sarah, but he did really well. I get
to read a sentence that I didn't think I would
ever read about a student at Hillsdale College.
He is president of the entrepreneurship club
and he does a lot of volunteering and he's
an incredibly organized kid, but also he co-owned
and operated ... I'm just reading this, because
I can't believe it ... Beechwood Avenue Limited,
a startup clothing design firm that manufactures
and sells upscale men's attire, and this lasted
for a year and four months, which means I
guess it went bust after that time. Isn't
it like a dog walking on its hind legs? The
miracle was it was done at all.
Nick is among the senior class officers. He's
a very artful kid. Nick, are you walking up
here? Start walking. These kids came loaded
for  this year, and it
wasn't like the year Morel graduated when
they wanted Chuck Norris. Clarence Thomas
has been in the top five on the senior class
list to be commencement speaker for the sixteen
years that I have been here. I have never
been willing to invite him, and the reason
is I know how busy he is, and I've always
regarded it as an imposition. As you can tell,
I wish to be of service to him, rather than
the other way around. I've always told him
no, but this year he showed up, and Waylon
helped him, I think, with the argument that
perhaps Justice Thomas is offended that you
have not asked him.
That is sophism taken to a high pitch. Can
you imagine the poor Justice sitting there
in his chambers in the Supreme Court worrying
whether I'm going to ask him to come here
and to come here and?
I smiled when they said that, and I said,
"Okay, that's pretty good." I said, "I will
write that in the letter to him," and I did,
so we all owe a very great debt to Senior
Class President Nicholas Brown.
Nick Brown:
Good afternoon. Thank you to Dr. Arnn, Justice
Thomas, the rest of the platform party, faculty
and staff, parents and friends. Without you,
this wouldn't the celebration it ought to
be. To my fellow graduates, congratulations.
I think we finally made Hillsdale great again.
It truly is an honor to stand before you today,
and I thank you for that. When I first visited
Hillsdale College, it was President's Day
2012. To celebrate, winter brought the only
gift it could, with one of the worst blizzards
the college had ever suffered. Dr. Arnn addressed
those of us who would come anyway. He said,
"We put the college in Michigan, because how
would you get the work done if you lived somewhere
warm?" That struck me as a weird sales pitch,
but weirder yet, it worked.
Now, for years later, no one here needs a
sales pitch for Hillsdale college, not at
this point, at least I hope not, but maybe
we could benefit from one final sales pitch
for the liberal arts, a defense of what we
just spent four years doing. In our age, western
heritage has been replaced with multicultural
studies and the honor code with political
correctness, and the confusion has gotten
so bad, we don't even know where to go to
the bathroom, yet here, we continue to embrace
the wisdom of the past.
Today, the liberal arts are under attack,
and Hillsdale College is the best defense
it could hope for. For weeks and months, as
we approached this day, many have asked us
the same question. "What are you going to
do?" We've heard it all of our lives. "What
do you want to be when you grow up?" It used
to be possible and even cute to say a basketball
star, but among us, the only person that can
say that without people laughing is Kyle Cooper.
The rest of us need a better answer. Now that
I'm all grown up, my answer is to be an entrepreneur.
I can't think of a better preparation for
this than the one the liberal arts has given
me.
I've heard it said that entrepreneurship is
living a few years of your life like most
people won't so that you can spend the rest
of your life like most people can't. The same
could be said for the liberal arts. Our Hillsdale
education has allowed us to live unlike most
other students. We have read the old books
and engaged in a dialogue which recognizes
that the answers are not easily found. We've
come to better understand ourselves, and we've
undertaken a profound inquiry. What we've
done is at its core entrepreneurial. Few of
my classmates would consider themselves entrepreneurs,
yet for all of us, the last four years have
been an entrepreneurial pursuit as we questioned,
analyzed, and searched.
The word "entrepreneur" comes from a thirteenth
century French verb "entreprendre," meaning
to do something or to undertake. In Dr. Steele's
"History of Economic Thought", we learn that
the first academic use of the word was likely
in 1730 by the economist Richard Cantillon.
He identified the willingness to bear the
financial risk of a business venture as the
defining characteristic of an entrepreneur.
This willingness to bear is essential for
any successful entrepreneur, but also for
the student of the liberal arts.
For the last four years, we have struggled
under the brilliance of the great thinkers.
The work which accompanied our pursuit was
hard, but the weight of the practice itself
was also silently present. Whether we recognized
it or not, the pursuit of the liberal arts
presents real danger to students, as we question
our perceived reality, evaluating the morays
which root us, we run the risk of being deceived
by sophistry.
Plato's "Protagoras" might be helpful here,
partly because I'm still trying to impress
Dr. Arnn, but mostly because Plato says something
worth knowing. "For I tell you, there is far
more serious risk in the purchase of doctrines
than in that of edibles. When you buy vitals
and liquors, you can take the advice of an
expert as to what is fit to eat or drink and
what is not, but you cannot carry away doctrines
in a separate vessel. You are compelled when
you handed over the price to take the doctrine
in your very soul by learning it, and so to
depart either an injured or a benefited man."
The kind of education we have embraced has
been rigorous, unrelenting, and even incendiary.
Pursued in solitude, it had the potential
to consume us and to leave us the slaves of
deceptive ideologies. Done correctly, it required
a partnership to sift through the appeals
of the great thinkers as we questioned the
legitimacy of their claims. In cooperation,
we chose to bear the burden of the liberal
arts because of all the questions it compels
us to ask.
Cantillon shows us that both entrepreneurship
and the liberal arts are inherently risky.
Yet another economist suggests the passion
for discovery moves both the entrepreneur
and the student to embrace this risk. For
Israel Kirzner, entrepreneurial discovery
gradually, but systematically, pushes back
the boundaries of sheer ignorance. Just as
the entrepreneur dissolves his ignorance in
the discovery of hidden opportunities, our
embrace of the liberal arts erases our ignorance,
driving us ever closer to a knowledge of the
truth.
At college, we grappled with the nature of
man, his purpose, and his role in the governance
of our society. We examined the concept of
justice and what it looked like rightly applied.
We questioned the efficacy of our modern world,
and we asked for advice from the greatest
thinkers of our heritage. In that rare instance,
what we thought we knew as proven true, though
more often, in a moment of disbelief, our
assumptions were exposed to be woefully inadequate.
For Kirzner, that surprise, which accompanies
the realization that one has overlooked something
in fact readily available, defines entrepreneurial
discovery, and it also encapsulates the liberal
arts. When viewed as an act of entrepreneurship,
our education begins as an embrace of introspection
aimed towards discovery and culminates in
an unexpected moment of awareness.
In this moment, when our ignorance is found
only to disappear, entrepreneurship and the
liberal arts arrive at their greatest potential.
No longer is either practice solitary, but
instead the focus now turns outward. As the
bible says in Galatians 5:13, "You, my brothers
and sisters, were called to be free, but do
not use your freedom to indulge the flesh.
Rather, serve one another humbly in love."
To some, entrepreneurship and the liberal
arts seem like selfish acts. The entrepreneur
innovates for profit, and the student seeks
after knowledge, but in these individual pursuits,
something amazing happens. When the discovery
of opportunity is followed by action, we begin
to serve others.
For the entrepreneur to profit, he must innovate,
creating a solution to the problem he has
encountered. He puts his discovered knowledge
to work by improving the lives of others,
and the student of the liberal arts can do
the same. In our study of the good, the true,
and the beautiful, we have inherited a unique
opportunity to apply our discovery to the
pursuit of our life. In everything that we
do, if we embrace the liberal arts as our
guide post, we become equipped to lead those
who are lost. The education, then, which is
truly enlightened, is not content simply to
contemplate, but rather aims to put contemplation
into practice. When we unite the revealed
truth of the liberal arts with our vocation,
our education equips us for influence.
In Shakespeare's "The Tempest" ... This one's
for you, Dr. Whalen ... Prospero serves as
a warning to the one who abandons his duty
to others for his zealous pursuit of the contemplative
of life, "I, thus neglecting worldly ends,
all dedicated to closeness and the bettering
of my mind with that which, but by being so
retired, o'erprized all popular rate, in my
false brother awakened an evil nature, and
my trust, like a good parent, did beget of
him a falsehood in its contrary as great as
my trust was, which had indeed no limit, a
confidence sans bound."
Prospero's selfish pursuit of knowledge came
with a cost. The avocation of his duty to
rule brought only hardship, leaving his nation
exposed and his family exiled. To pursue knowledge
for itself can leave one alone, absent, and
eventually insignificant. Our education then
must pursue knowledge with an appeal to our
greater purpose. Economics has provided me
with an understanding of how the world works,
but literature and humanities have shown us
what the world ought to be. The beauty of
the liberal arts is found in this dialogue
between what is and what could be.
As we leave the seclusion of coffee breaks
at AJ's and lectures on monopoly markets,
we must be reminded that there's work to be
done. The world increasingly embraces all
that is wrong, false, and ugly. We are among
the lonely few who have all the right questions.
None of us made a mistake in embracing the
liberal arts. To those who suggest otherwise,
ask them, "What is the good?" My friends,
we can do that now.